kadhafi engagé par kim a raconté non
c'est vous galant b vous y sentez vous
avez là très embêté madame par la
situation
oui mais je ne comprends pas pourquoi un
samedi on semaine oui mais décidément la
mercury beach fait couler de l'encré
depuis ce matin accéder à la plage de
californie relève du parcours du
combattant
ce jour là nous savons pertinemment que
beaucoup de plaisanciers vous doit
entrer des beaux lots véhicule et puis
nous avons soigné ce jour-là président
s'est un peu plus mal quoi s'il est
embarrassé pour défendre en fait notre
notre chez nous mais c'est surtout pour
défendre un front de mer parce que nous
avons des activités professionnelles
concernant la pêche et on se sent
envahie par de la plaisance et cela fait
des années que les plaisanciers occupe
le port de pêche de façon anarchique les
construction de hangars et de ponton se
multiplient les bateaux de plaisance
sont en stationnement permanent au
milieu les embarcations des pêcheurs
malgré l'arrêté municipal qui date de
2016 ce n'est pas normal que nous on ne
nous autorise pas à améliorer notre
habitat ou sinon l'améliorer de très peu
et que l'on est d'aussi grandes
structures sur le même site que le nôtre
la non trouveront qu'il y à une
adéquation dans la chose et si jallet
devrait aller ou alors nous avons des
ports de plaisance salaires ont en face
d'eux nous montrent qu'à brute et un
autre à côté les temps abricots line up
de port lay par pont nous avons un port
de pêche à californie est pas un port de
plaisance vous essayez les autorités
tous sont en cours le site se dégradent
progressivement la mangrove
elle aussi est altéré par les allées et
venues des plaisanciers des visiteurs en
plus de la dégradation de
l'environnement
les riverains se plaignent de nuisances
sonores à toute heure à californie le
blocage se poursuit pendant le tour des
yoles